I've always wanted to and I think the
other boys can detest to this but like
I've always wanted to ask you and I'm
pretty sure I asked you personally about
how you got to do your tip or do you oh
I could believe because I [ __ ] love
TED talk is it as a meme yeah so yeah we
really wanted to know which was oh we
don't know how you got that how that
opportunity came up and like just just
walks through the whole process TED talk
about being a huge achievement in North
Japan and talking about what it's like
there's a big toe Hawker University
which is one of the top three
universities in Japan while actually and
they were like do a TED talk on how
YouTube can be used as a way of
encouraging people to come and talk all
right but I was quite nervous at public
speaking because doing this where it's
three four drunkards in a room just two
thousand people going it's because like
there's no feedback you're just talking
to a camera you know I'm not making a
fool of myself in front of people I
think I'm too British bigoted oh yeah I
warning I want to do a TED like
ironically said like I would love to do
it what about about it later jelly do
honestly if someone was like you do a
TED talk about white animes or something
like [ __ ] yeah exactly it's going
something a passion about how YouTube is
a great tool for promoting North Japan I
had lots to say given that I'd done it
for five years of that I mean yeah I saw
the video and you seemed like quite
natural yeah yeah who is the last
[ __ ] Speaker of the day and I was
like as I said I'm nervous doing
probably speaking yeah yeah and this is
the biggest speech I've ever done in
front of a crowd 2,000 people or
something everyone's talking and I'm the
last one I'm just sitting there like
shake and then you go up and you're like
I need to act cool and I'm like yes and
there's like a timer before you O king
timer
oh god 15 minutes go
14:57 people of YouTube like was there a
part of you really should have timed
this to one minute and I went in ten
seconds over I remember watching loads I
remember I watched Ken Robinson which is
a really good TED talk Kelly talked
about how schools kill creativity when
the best speeches on Ted and one the
biggest most viewed it's a great speech
I just thought I'll just do that
20 times I'll just walk by him across
stage deliver lines like this in
intonation and I just I remember I
comment like mimicking his intonation I
understand Ken Robinson did you do like
a lot of prep I scripted the speech and
then in my apartment the day before I
let used it really go I just did it once
twice look at a leech are five times
cross and that's all there is to it huh
yeah it wasn't too bad because obviously
you can just wing it
yeah yeah right right I did a Japanese
speech contest once and in that Zappa
lays and you're not allowed to deviate
from your own script because the judges
how have all script script in front of
perfect and so I done that and that was
obscenely complicated it's the process
of that like how did you get that like
how did you get into that and then focus
on like one paragraph a day he was here
it was a 50-minute speech delivered
entirely Japanese I really English
translated it and affected it and then I
just broke it down to paragraphs
right used a memorization technique to
get through it at that point how good
was your Japanese speech all I could the
conversational lasting conversations two
years okay yeah and they gave avoid does
another speech contest and I just forgot
it I got like three yeah my video I see
paragraphs I saw this I know oh [ __ ]
Bob's hard to read off a sheet and I was
really learn from that experience it
makes you have enough [ __ ] speech
contest so I'm gonna do it
and it works really well but so doing
that really prepare me for the TED talk
and after that TED talk I was like okay
I don't feel that nervous about public
speaking anymore now I talk if you got
the offer sorry what'd you do another
TED talk probably don't talk about
awesome japanies yeah value if strumsy
why the West need strong